Bốn những chuyển bay trên khóc nông Mỹ đã bị hoán trong emu bay thống mời khi nhiều kệm sát viên không liều nghĩ việc vì không được chả lớn trong thời gian chính phủ để mang đầu gửa.
Cú thể có quan hàng không li vào Mỹ, AI cho biết tình chẳng thiếu như sự khuyến hoạt động tại nhiều sân bay lớn như New Walk, Denver và Las Vegas, giới vào phụ luật.
Một số trục tâm kệm suốt chỉ còn khoảng 5% quần số cần thiết.
Bột 5% trên trăm như sự có lại phải làm việc sau ngày mỗi tôn và tăng kale tục AI hiện đang thiếu khoảng 5% kìa.
Một số tiến số bị bình thường kể tự khi chính phủ đến bão hoạt kìa tên liện ngon sát giò lựa đảng không đại được đồng thuật.
Quảng mời bán nghiệm kiểm soát viên không liều và năm miền đến viên cũng an ninh bận tại TSI vẫn phải làm việc mà không được chả lớn.
Thếu chế phí sinh hoạt có bối bản chất công việc kăng thằng cường đồ cao khiến nhiều người xin gỷ hoặc bà ủng.
Lâm gián đoạn nghiêm trọng hệ thống hàng không cu ra ngoài lý vực hàng không, của khu khoảng nân sát hai tôn qua cú khiến khoảng mới trên năm miền đến viên bán vài tạm mi việc
và khoảng 1 in bà trọng tì đối lỗi Mỹ chi têu công bị đồng bán trước tình cạnh này tổ thông viên đường tên bố sẵn sàng đối thoại về phay dần chủ để thảo gượng bế tạm.
Sao nhìn mạnh, chính phủ cần đuất mật gờ trở lại trước khi bán về các trình chính gỷ tế.